هذا هو عرضت وحده الظل التابعه لكتائب
القسام الجناح العسكري لحركه حماس سلاح
الجندي الاسرائيلي هدار جولدن الاسير لدى
القسام منذ عام 2000 و 2014
وقالت الوحده في كلمه لها خلال احتفاليه
الذكرى الخامسه والثلاثين لتاسيس الحركه
ان السلاح هو غنيمه من غنائم عمليه اسر
الضابط الاسرائيلي وان القسام تمتلك رصيدا
مهما في هذا الملف
في سياق ذاته شددا القائد العام لكتائب
القسام الجناح العسكري لحركه حماس محمد
الضيف على ضروره توحيد كل الرايات
والجبهات لتحرير فلسطين وقال في رساله
صوتيه خلال مهرجان لحركه حماس للذكرى
الخامسه وثلاثين لانطلاقتها في غزه ان
الاحتلال عجز سابقا عن استئصال الشعب
الفلسطيني او تمصه هويته وهو اعجز واجبا
من ان ينجح في ذلك اليوم
وفقا تعبير
نقول لقياده العدو وجمهوره ايها الغرباوي
عن ارضنا لقد عجز ابائكم المؤسسون وهم في
قمه جبروتهم وانتمائهم لفكره الصهيونيه
الخبيثه عن استئصال شعبنا او طمس هويتنا
فانتم اليوم اعجز واجمل من ان تنجحوا في
ما فشل فيه اباؤكم وستكون نهايتكم وزوال
كيانكم وكانسكم عن ارضنا هي غنيمتنا مواعد
ربنا الذي لن يتاخر عنكم باذن الله
وتتوحد كل الرايات والتلتئم كل الجبهات
والتفتح كل الساحات لهدف واحد غايه كبيره
نبيله مقدسه وهي تحرير فلسطين واعادتها
الى حضن الاسلام